So I've been in touch over the last couple
of weeks with some of our viewers in Hong
Kong and one in particular has [inaudible].
You've been sending me videos, videos that
have been taken by others, some posted on
social media from Hong Kong, some taken by
the viewers, family themselves.
And I have a video for you today that that
is utterly insane in a despicable sight to
behold.
And the video is of what appear to be police
on motorcycles running over protesters at
high speed.
This is not, you know, someone's toe caught
under a motorcycle tire in a confusing moment
accidentally or something like that.
This is police or what appear to be police
revving up and accelerating at high speed
and hitting protestors.
Of course, viewer discretion is advised, all
of that stuff.
I know this is very visual, so if you're merely
listening to the podcast or on the radio today,
you won't get the full scope.
But indulge me for the 28 seconds that we're
about to watch.
And then I encourage you to find the video
on our YouTube channel.
[inaudible]
absolutely and utterly insane.
And things in Hong Kong just don't appear
to be slowing down at all.
In fact, violence may be getting worse.
Lawmakers, uh, who are activating for democracy
have been facing arrest.
Police have been using more and more a tear
gas protestors are blocking main roads, cars
are being lit on fire.
A man was actually set on fire a couple of
days ago.
We heard from a Hong Kong, uh, police senior
superintendent who said quote, over the past
two days, our society has been pushed to the
brink of a total breakdown that can be interpreted
in at least two or three different ways depending
on which side of the protests you find yourself
on.
Here's video of people being pepper sprayed
or teargassed at close range.
This video is reminiscent of that.
Remember that CIC police officer, I think
his name was Lieutenant pike, John pike, I
believe at UC Berkeley some years ago.
Just at point blank range, uh, spraying almost
like you would with, with sunscreen.
Spang spraying protesters, uh, with tear gas.
This is video from Bloomberg in Hong Kong.
[inaudible].
So right now, this is, this is just horrible
stuff.
A district council elections are set for November
24 but the longer that this goes, the more
people are fearing China could get involved
and pressure Hong Kong to postpone those elections.
Even to go around Hong Kong's legislature
all together to pass national security legislation
as they're calling it police shooting at protestor.
That video went viral.
The man set on fire.
I told you about that video going viral.
The man was arguing with protesters.
He was some kind of flammable liquid, I don't
know if it was alcohol or or, or a gasoline
thrown on him and then lit on fire.
We have those videos.
I'm not going to play them right now, but
you can easily find them online if you're
so inclined.
I genuinely have no idea how this will settle.
It's getting uglier and uglier.
Uh, I would say by the day, certainly by the
week and no sign whatsoever of a deescalation
anytime soon.
So that's my question to you.
If you think ahead a week, a month, six months,
however long, what do you see as even having
the potential to deescalate circumstances?
I don't know the answer.
I want to hear from you.
Leave a reply if you're watching on YouTube
or send me a tweet at D Pacman, if you are
watching or listening elsewhere.